we do have an update about the Trump
Russia connection we had this question
throughout the entire campaign how much
Trump coordination happened with Russia
how much contact was there and there's
been a notable lack of criticism from
the right about what seemed to be
connections between Trump and Russia and
there's also been a notable benefit to
Donald Trump's campaign from believed
Russian hacking and of course we had
these suspicions that part of the reason
why the Trump tax returns weren't
released was because it would have
exposed a Russia connection which I
guess would have been damaging although
like he'd like from said he could shoot
people on Fifth Avenue his supporters
would still support him he could
probably reveal connections to Russia
financial connections and his supporters
more than likely would still support him
well it's all come off the walls in the
last week senior Russian diplomat and
deputy foreign minister that this is
this I can't even believe I'm doing this
story Pat skies name is Sergei Reba
Ryabkov rehab cough probably the
pronunciation as I mentioned is the
deputy foreign minister in Russia he's
confirmed that Russian government
officials were communicating directly
with members of Donald Trump's campaign
team he was quoted as saying we have
just begun to consider ways of building
dialogue with the future Donald Trump
administration and channels we will be
using for those purposes now immediately
Trump spokeswoman hope hick said oh yeah
that's not true we had no contact with
Russian officials before Tuesday's
elections I want to be super super clear
Donald Trump has denied many times
having financial or other ties to Moscow
period if that ends up being proven
false to any extent it will be yet
another example of the not politician
lies but just flat-out bold-faced lies
of the Trump campaign and this is not
proof Pat this statement from the
Russian diplomat is not proof you can
make the argument that he's saying this
specifically to make Trump look bad at
this point it's pretty clear that
Vladimir Putin sees Trump as an
opportunity to have sanctions lifted on
Russia so it doesn't strike me as sort
of motivationally precise or accurate
too
that rushes just going to make this up
because they want Trump to reduce
sanctions on them this is not proof but
it is very concerning it proof did
surface it wouldn't be surprising at all
because Trump second campaign manager
Paul Manafort actually had to resign yet
because he had lobbying times to uh Pro
Russian oligarchs in Ukraine and some of
the stuff doesn't even have to be a
clandestine operation Trump at a rally
asked for Russian hackers to produce the
30,000 missing emails yeah from Hillary
Clinton yeah right out in the open right
out of the open and one of the more
interesting countries to watch over the
next four years is going to be Russia
they got a green light from Washington
DC that that they are no longer going to
stand in the way it's hard to predict
the outcome but I think a far more
aggressive Russia is obvious what they
plan on doing with this increased
aggressiveness is not totally clear but
it's very clear that the broader goal
will be Putin wants Russia legitimized
as a mainstream top player in
geopolitics it's also important to feed
Vladimir Putin's ego that's always a top
priority in Russia think about how
backwards this campaign was Republicans
claim to hate infrastructure spending
Trump had the biggest infrastructure
spending proposal of anybody Republicans
love getting involved as the world
policemen Trump says no getting involved
with Middle East dictators similar
position to Bernie Sanders Republicans
still vote for him and of course
republicans don't like Russia they
criticized Obama as a [ __ ] for not
starting a war with Russia and Russia
invaded Ukraine and now I'm sure they'll
praise Trump for quote dealing
pragmatically with the Russians by
letting them do whatever the hell they
want and letting up Vladimir Putin play
Trump like a violin it is amazing what
Republicans voted for and prediction it
will be amazing what Republicans except
in the name of a Republican president
and honestly I don't know whether to be
concerned or relieved that Trump isn't
practicing a lot of the things that he
preached over the campaign ya know about
it in many ways we don't want Trump to
do a lot of the stuff he said he would
during his campaign it will just be
interesting if it's fun in a way where
his supporters don't even realize that
he doesn't do it but plenty of time for
that let's take a break after the break
I want to talk about something people
have emailed me over the weekend
and about and I've really been thinking
about is the president of the United
States still the leader of the free
world if that president is Donald Trump
we'll talk about that next join us on
reddit at david pakman.com slash reddit
that is re d di t